money money money money money  alright welcome to the chest minute I am  the 1998 Missouri scholastic state  champion Michael comer back out of  retirement they were like hey and I was  like alright one minute you got me for  one minute and so I'm doing great  America very exciting time to be alive  last night I played a sixteen ninety in  blitz and let's just see how it goes I  start out before I am the white pieces  oh don't do it don't do it all night of  six so here we know what happens here  the fried liver attack so he takes and  now Knight takes he's like alright free  night Chuck you protects the night and  what are we doing up in pieces attack  and now he's like it's like bad news  buddy you're about to get sizzle check  and I got more bad news for ya  he likes jazz - and now checkmate  game over yes if I had a hundred dollar  bill for every time I crush somebody at  the fried liver I'd be able to retire 35